[Music]
good morning John it's Monday October
1st the good news is that you missed the
most of the really sick part of me being
sick and that's good because you didn't
want to see it because it was gross I'm
mostly just sort of coughing all the
time
but I'm just better than the faucet face
that I had earlier this weekend would
pretty much required me to do my video
with toilet paper stuffed up my nose
maybe it wouldn't have been putting my
best face forward I've been missing a
lot lately people putting stuff on their
heads I don't think the spending off
that going around lately
you can tweet deny it there's something
about putting stuff in your head this is
presently fun and interesting I don't
know if it's like is interesting is
putting stuff on your cat if you've ever
been at that website obviously I have
stuff on cat calendar here but I think
it might be a little bit more liberating
like we can put stuff on our cats yeah
the cats don't mind sometimes they do
cameo she sure does she's not a stuff on
your cat cat she's up put stuff on you
know he do in your face Kent the
question becomes would you rather put
stuff on your head or would you wanna
put stuff on your cat now this is an
important question because I think we
need to realize that so fun Kansas is
cute but stuff on people is important
I'm very proud of being able to save to
the world yes there is a golden string
dangling from the bottom of my lip but I
think there's something important there
which is why I'm considering launching a
website called stuff on heads comm now I
can't do this without supportive
nerdfighters so what I need are people
who believe in stuff on heads people who
will do it themselves people who will
sort through other people's stuff on
heads people who know how to use
WordPress and people who realize that
ridiculousness is an important facet of
modern humanity continue to respect the
notion that being foolish is extremely
important
you don't know what I'm talking about go
back and watch the original stuff on my
head video I'll put a link to it
somewhere so if you believe in the cause
if you believe that life can be improved
by ripping yourself out of the norm
please ah I want to see people putting
stuff on their heads and I want to see
people doing it in public and I want to
see people enjoying it I'm gonna start a
thread about this in my pants which is
now fully restored to its original form
this I'm sorry about that let's look to
the future putting stuff on your head is
not a fad it is a way of life
nerdfighters I need you let's band
together let us do this thing stuff on
heads com coming soon
John I'm curious what you think and I
will see you tomorrow